yes i know i should not be doing this
comparison but you know what
this is my mac pro and this is my mac
mini
and we're going to put them head to head
and you know what you're going to be
absolutely shocked in some of these
tests hey guys it's max before we jump
in i have to say thank you for helping
us reach
500 000 subscribers before the end of
the year we absolutely appreciate it
and for those of you guys that are not
yet subscribed our next milestone is
march which is going to mark two years
of us doing this channel
we want to hit 600k before then so if
you want to see
me ditch the mac pro replace it for
daily use
with the mac mini and report back make
sure to hit that subscribe button and
help us reach our next goal
now as you guys can see there's a
massive price difference between these
two machines
and a pretty big spec difference as well
my mac mini is under a g
compared to 15 000 for the mac pro now
of course not everything is apples to
apples on this spec sheet
but if we go ahead and get rid of the
afterburner which doesn't help in most
of the tests we'll be looking at
and we bump down our ram to 48 gigs
which is pretty much comparable with 16
gigs of unified ram here and we drop the
ssd storage the macro is still coming in
right around 10 000 about 10 times that
of the mac mini now yes there is a
reason why the mac pro costs
this much money the whole case the
design
the xeon cpus the ecc memory we have
tons of pci slots so there's so much you
can upgrade
yourself mine also has eight thunderbolt
3 ports compared to just
two on the mac mini i also have an hdmi
just like the mac mini does
and the mac mini will support two
external displays compared to the mac
pro that supports
four maybe 6k displays i also have two
10 gigabit ethernet ports compared to
just standard one gigabit ethernet so
this is a professional machine
with expensive professional parts but
what i want to know
is how does it perform in most of the
tasks that i use we're going to look at
photo editing video editing
logic x code some gaming performance
how much power these use temperatures
and more let's start out by comparing
the 12 core processor to the 8 core and
the m1 for those cores are actually
efficiency cores not performance cores
i'm going to start out with geekbench
5 and as far as the single core
performance
the mac mini is 56
faster the single core performance with
the mac mini and the other m1 max
is just off the charts beating every
other cpu
out there and you can actually tell
day-to-day opening folders applications
simple things are super quick on the mac
mini now as far as multi-core this is
where the mac pro shines with a score
that is 63
higher and it's gonna be interesting to
see how this affects real world
performance
now geekbench tests a wide variety of
tasks and most of them don't max out the
cpu
so let's take a look at cinebench r23
which i haven't yet ran
on the mac pro until doing this video
and here the mac pro was 83 percent
more powerful or got 83 higher score now
that is
a pretty big difference but honestly i
was expecting
a bigger difference because the mac pro
actually uses
up to 193 watts compared to the new mac
mini which only uses 13 watts
which is absolutely mind-blowing and
that's because it's not only an arm
design which is efficient
it's also a 5 nanometer processor
compared to much older
14 nanometer design and because of that
it actually gets 594 points per watt
compared to 73 points per watt on the
mac pro
now as far as temperatures i was
actually shocked to see that the mac
mini
is actually cooler as well the old mac
mini
the fan would run at full blast the
intel 6 core
and it would be running at like 97
degrees celsius it was crazy
this new one actually maxed out at 72
and that is the hottest that the high
performance cores got
the high efficiency cores are actually
much cooler and the mac pro was at 85
under full load and the other awesome
thing is both of these fans were running
at idle the slowest speeds they could so
the systems are
silent and now let's talk about graphics
my mac pro has the vega 2
with 32 gigabytes of memory that's
doubled in the whole system in the mac
mini
which actually shares the 16 gig with
the cpu and graphics
and with geekbench 5's metal test the
mac pro
scores over 4 times the performance 22
000 compared to 98 000 now as far as
gaming i use gfx bench which is
optimized for metal and that's all the
games coming out on mac
and here instead of over four times the
performance
we actually got about two and a half
times performance on the mac
pro now along with that what is
absolutely mind-blowing is that the gpu
only uses 5.6 watts compared to the mac
pro which uses somewhere between 200 to
250 watts
i couldn't find any way to get an
accurate readout like i did on the mac
mini
and that means that instead of getting
about 14 frames per second
per watt it actually got one frame per
second on the mac pro or even
less than that so as far as efficiency
of course these new macs are crazy
but of course we're not using batteries
on these so it doesn't really matter
like it does
with the macbook air or the macbook pro
now let's talk about the ssds
both of these have ultra fast ones you
can't upgrade the mac pro but you have
to buy
apple's expensive ssds whereas the mini
is built in now just got the base
storage option
and taking a look at speeds as far as
read they are very similar but
for write speed the mac pro is about 600
megabyte per second faster
getting further into performance let's
talk about web browsing
so i ran the speedometer 2.0 using
safari
and the mac mini is actually 72
faster in web browsing i definitely
noticed the difference going between the
mac pro
to the imacs the new ones the 2020s and
then going to the m1 mac mini
everything is just faster it's snappier
almost instant
where i do have to wait a little bit
when i switch pages on the mac pro
not a big complaint but it definitely is
noticeable
and now let's talk about audio
production we tested
logic pro and here the mac mini actually
pulled off
90 tracks before it crashed so it's
great performance and it did that
completely silent
now the mac pro on the other hand
actually could run
220 tracks also completely silent so as
far as logic the mac pro is definitely
on another level but with that said the
m1
is plenty for most people and now let's
talk about coding we're testing the max
tech benchmark that maxim ermenko made
for us and our mac pro
took 125 seconds to compile this
project here whereas the mac mini
it took 120 seconds so it was actually
five seconds faster
even though you have way less ram you
have less performance
it is just incredibly optimized for
xcode
and now let's get into photo editing i
am using lightroom classic
and yes that means that this program is
not optimized for apple silicon
yet so we're using rosetta to translate
it to be able to run
and let's just start out by talking
about the photo editing experience
and using both of these i really can't
tell a difference
um as far as moving the sliders doing my
standard adjustments
now as far as brushes the mac mini has a
little bit of delay when you first start
out
but the mac pro actually works the same
exact way it gets a little bit of lag at
the start
and then it's perfectly smooth so that
is identical
and then as far as switching between
these images for some
reason the mac mini is slightly more
responsive
slightly faster when i'm switching
through which really
doesn't make sense but as far as editing
both these do a great job and you don't
have to wait
for photo editing applications to be
optimized
it works great now as far as exporting i
went ahead and exported 50 of these 42
megapixel images with a bunch of
corrections
and the mac pro absolutely smokes the
mac mini now i was expecting that
because
in our previous tests we noticed that
with the six channel
memory in the mac pro is quite a bit
faster than the 4 channel memory in the
imac pro
in dual channel memory in the regular
imac
even though the imax performance of the
cpu is
very similar to the mac pro the 10 core
model so
channel memory really makes a difference
here i also built one-to-one previews
because a lot of you guys
asked for that and once again the mac
pro is quite a bit faster
and now let's get into video editing
something that we do a ton of
here at max tech i'm going to focus on
final cut if you want to know the
results in premiere pro and davinci
resolve as well
i'll leave a link to my other channel in
the video description and i'll make a
much more detailed video in the future
now let's jump into bruce x which tests
out the graphics card's performance and
here the mac pro is a little bit more
than twice as powerful
and that's interesting to see because
the actual metal performance in
geekbench
is more than four times as powerful so
it looks like we're getting some
optimization here in final cut
now stabilizing on one minute 4k
file h.265 the mac mini
is actually faster it's getting close to
being twice as fast
which is crazy but that is because this
new apple silicon m1 chip has really
fast decoders
much faster than the older vega 2
graphics card and that helps
with this new kind of footage that's
coming out in most new cameras
getting into 4k video editing smoothness
the mac mini has no issues
even though i have a couple luts applied
i have film grain it is playing it back
perfectly just like the mac pro and this
is the kind of footage that most people
work with now as far as
exporting a five minute project the mac
pro is faster by about 34 seconds
not really a big deal there i did want
to see if this was a gpu limitation
because
obviously a graphics card is much slower
in the mac mini so i took off all the
effects
and the times didn't change at all
meaning we're just limited by the
encoders
not the graphics performance i then
switched over to a similar project but
using this new h.265
footage and playing back is no issue
with both of these
with color correction and the effects on
here and then
exporting it the mac mini was actually
faster than the mac pro
by five seconds because of the new
decoders and with those new decoders we
have to talk about
canon 10 bit footage this is from the
canon r5 and my mac pro as you see it's
just stuttering it can't handle this
footage
even though it's so powerful in terms of
hardware
moving over to the mac mini it's playing
this back
perfectly smoothly now i also exported a
five minute project and the mac mini
exported it two and a half times
faster that is just crazy once again
because of those decoders so not only
can you play it back perfectly
you can actually export it much faster
as well now
people with other macs the new imacs mac
pros other systems
they are having to transcode this
footage to prores or other formats
before they can edit it smoothly which
is what i had to do
before so i did want to do a transcoding
test i transcoded 30 minutes of footage
the mac pro took 30 minutes but the mac
mini did the same task
in 13 minutes so yes it was about two
and a half times
faster once again and that is just
incredible as far as 4.5 k red raw the
mac mini actually played it back
not perfectly but close to that it is
smooth enough to edit of course the mac
pro has no issues
in exporting this five-minute project
with film grain applied and luts
the mac pro was two and a half times
faster so definitely a big noticeable
difference
and then stepping up to 8k it actually
doesn't play back
this 8k perfectly it plays back at 22
frames per second so it's close
whereas the mac mini plays back at three
frames per second
it is horrible to look at now with that
said
final cut has an option to go to better
performance mode and i don't like using
this for 4k it makes the footage look
terrible but for 8k
it still looks good enough to edit and
judge focus off of and then the mac midi
actually plays it back perfectly
smoothly it is
really usable which is shocking now as
far as the exporting times
i tested this to 8k prores and the mac
pro was close to four
times faster just because this test
maxes out the cpu and maxes out the
graphics card
uses a lot of ram and the mac pro
obviously is a way more powerful system
so as far as 4k raw 8k raw you are
better off with the mac pro
and along with that for people that are
editing standard 4k
for most of you guys out there the mac
mini is more than good enough
in final cut so what is our verdict well
obviously this is a bit of a silly
comparison these systems are way
different but with that said
for most video editors the m1 is just
fine in final cut like i mentioned
for photo editors this thing is works
just as well in lightroom which is
shocking
and then also for xcode it beats out the
mac pro
for music production if you're going
really high-end you still want a mac pro
but for everybody else
the mac mini does a shockingly good job
at this
and overall it is just crazy how good it
performs so
if you guys want to see me plug this in
and then give you guys a one week later
comparison real world what i noticed not
just these
tests that i ran here let me know down
in the comments section i have links to
both
in the video description click that
circle above if you guys want to help us
reach 600
000 before our two year mark that would
be amazing we have a couple other great
videos right over there
this has been max and i'll catch you in
the next video